to a royal drama in japan where princess
mako has had to leave the royal family
after marrying her long-time boyfriend a
commoner following japanese law the
marriage has split public opinion with
some critics considering her now husband
unfit for the princess
the couple skipped the usual rituals of
a royal wedding and marco apologized for
any trouble brought by her marriage
so for more on this story let's speak to
michelle lee tokyo bureau chief of the
washington post very warm welcome
michelle tell us more about today's
ceremony it wasn't what we usually
expect to see from a royal wedding
no there wasn't a ceremony at all it was
a staff member of the imperial house
agency who went to the registry office
and submitted their marriage documents
and that was it
she was not allowed to have a
traditional ceremony because her family
decided that because of the public
criticism about their marriage that it
wouldn't be a celebratory event for the
public and therefore it would be a very
muted uh very paper-driven logistical up
there
after that after they made their
marriage official they did hold a news
conference which is the first time the
couple appeared in public
since 2017 when they got engaged and
they appeared together it was very
somber they read a joint statement but
it was very clear it was an emotional
event for them they talked about their
love how difficult the past couple years
have been for them with the public
criticism and they talked about how they
had been there for each other and they
did apologize for the people they had
upset but thanked those who had
supported them to help us understand why
exactly has their relationship been
attracting so much public criticism
well it wasn't always so critical in
2017 when
they announced their engagement the
public was very happy for them they were
happy for the princess their love story
was very sweet the couple talked about
how they fell in love with each other
and giggled and it was a very sweet
announcement but shortly thereafter
some news reports emerged about his
mother's
finances and some drama that she had
with her ex-fiance so it gets a little
bit complicated but when these stories
uh surfaced the japanese public became
very critical and skeptical of him and
wondered whether he was taking advantage
of the princess about the connections to
the imperial family whether he was uh
quite fit for the princess whether he
was good enough and then it really
snowballed from there it seemed like he
couldn't do anything right in the
public's eye when he showed up at the
airport in japan a couple weeks ago he
was wearing a ponytail his hair was in a
ponytail and his ponytail literally
ended up in headlines and people
criticized him for that and when the
princess talked about her post-traumatic
stress disorder symptoms from all of
this criticism
they mocked her for that too it has been
quite brutal there were protests in fact
there was a protest today of about 150
people who were holding signs and
chanting and and opposing their marriage
okay so i love story that's turned quite
nasty i'm just briefly before we go what
is next for princess macko
well princess malcolm who is now mako
komoro
is headed to the united states with her
new husband
we think they're going to go to new york
where he works as a lawyer and she
has an art curation certificate she has
a background in art studies and she's
apparently very much wanted in the arts
community already
okay love story moving to new york then
michelle lee the tokyo bureau chief of
the washington post thanks so much for
joining us on dw